بعد شهرين عندما ظهروا أخيرًا
في النور ، كان
العالم المدمر الذي
ينتظرهم طريق الخروج من خلال هذا ماريو بول
مثل مصنع الصلب الأنيق الذي ضربته
المتفجرات الروسية لأسابيع يمكن
بسهولة أن يخطئ بالخطوات
الأولى للجحيم
ولكن الإنقاذ في انتظاره  نهايتها هؤلاء
الأوكرانيون الذين عانوا من
قعقعة الانفجارات الوحشية أعلاه ممتنون
لإخراجهم حتى لو كان عبر مدينة لا
يمكن التعرف عليها الآن ،
تحولت سفيتوسلاف ستة أشهر في اليوم
السابق لقولهم أن الزارع قضى ثلث
حياته تحت الأرض.
يقول إن
البالغين الذين تعرفهم يمكنهم الانتظار
ولكن هذه كانت بداية ربما
الآلاف من الرحلات المماثلة هنا
برفقة الأمم المتحدة والصليب الأحمر
أثناء توقف قصير في
أعمال العنف بعد أسابيع من التملق في
موسكو وكييف على أعلى مستوى ،
شكرًا لك وحافظ على صحتك  وتقول إن
الخروج من
هذه الصور التي تم تصويرها في
منطقة تسيطر عليها روسيا يظهر على ما يبدو
بعض التحركات الأولى للخروج من
ماريوبول  مسترشدين بالأمم المتحدة
، لا يزالون هنا تحت حراسة مسلحة روسية
، وزعمت وزارة الدفاع الروسية يوم
الاثنين أن 11 من الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم
قرروا البقاء في الأراضي التي يسيطرون عليها و 69
للتوجه إلى زاباريزيا التي كانت تحتفظ بها أوكرانيا
حتى يوم الاثنين قبل الغسق ، ولم يكن
أي من القافلة حتى اليوم.  على غرار أو
عشرات الآلاف من المدنيين الأوسع نطاقاً الذين
قد يرغبون في الخروج في حركة الأمم المتحدة ،
وصلوا هنا
إلى مركز ترحيب حيث
كان الناس يصلون ببطء من ماريو بول الأوسع نطاقاً
في المناطق المحيطة به تحت سيطرتهم الخاصة
خلال الرحلات التي امتدت في الأيام السابقة
تاتيانا  قالت إنها خرجت من مسبح ماريو
قبل ثلاثة أيام ، لقد قصفوا المباني
وهي ألسنة اللهب ، تقول إن الجثث
دفنت روحها التي لم تنكسر عندما
حاولت النهوض والمشي قبل أن تذكر
أن كرسيها المتحرك موجود لغرض ما
في الأيام المقبلة  ستكون الأرقام التي
تصل إلى هنا
نذير شؤم عما إذا كان أي نوع من
الحديث في هذه الحرب يمكن أن ينقذ أرواح نيك
بايتون والش سي إن إن زاباريزيا أوكرانيا